The plaintiffs in most
copyright infringement suits
are interested in money in addition
to, or sometimes instead of,
the kind of injunctive relief
considered in the previous segment
of this lecture.
In the United States,
such plaintiffs are
able to rely on three
different principles
when seeking financial recoveries.
First, they could
obtain "actual damages".
In other words, enough money to
compensate them for the injuries
they have sustained.
Second, they can recover
profits made by the defendants
attributable to the
defendant's infringing behavior
so long as those profits are not
duplicative of the actual damages
sustained by the plaintiffs.
Last but not least,
instead of either actual
damages or lost profits, plaintiffs may
recover so-called statutory damages--
sums of money that bear
no necessary relationship
to either the magnitude of the
injuries the plaintiff sustained
or to the profits wrongfully
earned by the defendants.
The first two of these
forms of recovery,
actual damages and defendant's
profits, are conventional.
Although the methods by which
they are calculated in US courts
are somewhat unusual, these
two types of monetary recovery
may be found in the copyright systems
of most countries in the world
and indeed are often
granted to the victims
of many other kinds
of unlawful behavior,
both in the United States and elsewhere.
The third form of recovery,
by contrast, is unusual.
Relatively few countries currently
recognize so-called statutory damages
and there's considerable controversy
over whether they should.
I'll now spend about
20 minutes describing
how these three types of
financial recovery work.
When I'm done, I'll
step back from the trees
and consider the ongoing
debate concerning
which dimensions of this forest
make sense and which do not.
The statutory authority
for the first approach
is contained in section
504(b) of the statute.
As you can see, that provision
entitles a copyright owner
to recover "the actual
damages suffered by him
or her as a result of the infringement."
The purpose of this provision is
to enable a successful plaintiff
to recoup all of the money she
lost because of the defendant's
infringement.
The most clear cut example
consists of profits
the plaintiff would have
earned had the defendant not
encroached upon her
copyright unlawfully.
The conventional way of proving
such lost profits by the plaintiff
is to introduce evidence of the
volume of sales at the plaintiff
likely would have enjoyed in the
absence of the defendant's behavior
combined with evidence concerning
the profit the plaintiff would likely
have a earned on each of those sales.
A less well established
variant of this approach
permits the plaintiff to
recoup losses she sustained
if she was forced to reduce the price
of authorized copies of her work
in order to compete with
the infringing defendant.
This component of
actual damages certainly
makes sense as a matter of theory,
but case loss support for it is thin.
A recent addition to the set
of types of actual damages
is the so-called value of use theory.
The idea underlying this
variant is that a plaintiff
should be able to
recover from a defendant
an amount of money
equivalent to the license fee
that the defendant would have
paid to the plaintiff in order
to obtain permission to engage
in the conduct at issue.
Somewhat more specifically,
this variant permits a plaintiff
to recover from the defendant the
amount that a willing licensee would
have paid a willing licensor for
the right to engage in that conduct.
In determining that amount,
courts take into account
such factors as the customs prevailing
in the industry in question,
the terms on which the plaintiff
herself had previously granted licenses
to other parties to engage
in similar activities,
and perhaps special circumstances
that would have prompted the plaintiff
to demand unusually
high or low licensees.
As I say, this so-called
value of use theory
is a relatively recent innovation.
It was pioneered by the Seventh
Circuit Court of Appeals
in the Deltak case in 1985.
The Court of Appeals for the
Second Circuit, which, as you know,
enjoys disproportionate
influence in copyright law,
initially rejected this
basis of liability.
But in 2001, in the case
of Davis versus The Gap,
the Second Circuit embraced it.
A year later, the Ninth
Circuit did as well.
Nevertheless, the argument
remains highly controversial.
Critics contend that it fails to
take into account the likelihood
that if the defendant had been aware
of the illegality of his activity,
he might not have engaged in
it at all and thus would not
have paid the plaintiff
any license fees.
In short, the critics argue, this
theory gives the plaintiff a windfall.
Finally, some courts have been
willing to allow plaintiffs
to recover under the
heading of actual damages
sums of money necessary
to compensate them
for what might be described as
indirect or collateral injuries.
Included in this grab bag
are such things as money
the plaintiff was
forced to spend in order
to modify her own product to
compete with the defendant's
infringing product,
loss of goodwill because
of the presence in the market of
the defendant's infringing product
misled consumers into thinking that
the plaintiff's version was not unique,
and ancillary revenue that the plaintiff
may have lost because the defendant
failed to give her appropriate
credit for her creations.
Either the plaintiff
or the defendant may
insist that these issues be resolved by
a jury rather than by the trial judge.
The way in which burdens of
proof are allocated at trial
is that the plaintiff
bears the initial burden
of showing a reasonable
probability that there's
a causal connection
between the defendant's
infringing activities and
the plaintiff's injuries.
The defendant then has an opportunity
to rebut those assertions.
If he fails to do so, the
plaintiff is entitled to recover.
The statutory basis of
the plaintiff's a right
to recover the defendant's profits
is also contained in section 504(b).
As you can see, that provision
indicates that a copyright owner
is entitled to recover "any
profits of the infringer that
are attributable to the
infringement and are not
take into account in
computing actual damages."
The last clause in this
sentence prevents a plaintiff
from using this device to
achieve a double recovery.
In other words, any profit
the defendant reaped
that derived from sales
diverted from the plaintiff
must be excluded from the plaintiff's
recovery under this theory,
because they've already
been taken into account
under the heading of actual damages.
As a practical matter,
this exclusion means
that the opportunity to
recover a defendant's profits
is most beneficial to
plaintiffs in two situations.
First, where there are more than two
competitors in the relevant market
and thus that the
defendant's profits were
diverted not just from the plaintiff,
but also from a third party.
Second, where the defendant has a much
larger business than the plaintiff
and thus was able to sell many
more products than the plaintiff
could have done.
Burdens of proof under this
heading are allocated as follows.
The plaintiff must introduce evidence
of the defendant's gross revenues.
The statute, as you can see,
does not require the plaintiff
to show that the revenue at issue
is attributable to the defendant's
unlawful behavior.
But the courts have added
that important qualification
to the plaintiff's burden.
So what kinds of revenues
count under this standard?
The principal examples are
those I just mentioned.
Namely, revenues earned by the defendant
from sales of an infringing product.
What about revenues he earned from sales
of related non-infringing products that
were boosted in some way by
sales of the infringing products?
These are recoverable in
theory, but difficult to prove.
Occasionally courts have
also been willing to count
under this heading revenues generated by
advertisements created and distributed
by the defendants that
contain infringing material.
Usually, however, such
recoveries are denied
because the plaintiff
is unable to establish
a causal connection
between the advertisements
at issue and the
defendant's enhanced sales.
Finally, revenue attributable to the
enhancement of a defendant's goodwill
caused by his sales
of infringing products
are, again, recoverable in theory,
but almost never provable in practice.
Of course, the defendant's
gross revenue overstates
the magnitude of his illicit gain.
To determine his profit, we must deduct
from his revenues the associated costs.
For obvious reasons, the burden
to introduce evidence concerning
the magnitude of those costs is borne
by the defendant, not the plaintiff.
What kinds of expenditures may
fairly be counted as costs?
In answering that
question, courts typically
look to generally accepted
accounting principles.
An interesting nuance
under this heading is
that a defendant is
permitted to deduct income
taxes unless his
infringement was willful.
Intriguing issues arise when
the defendant's product consists
of a combination of infringing material
and non-infringing original material
contributed by the defendant.
Under such circumstances,
the defendant is
permitted to introduce evidence showing
what portion of the revenue generated
by the composite product is properly
attributable to his own non-infringing
contribution, and thus not
properly payable to the plaintiff.
Delicate and difficult
questions lurk here concerning
what features of products
matter to consumers.
Remember for example, the controversy
between the photographer Art Rogers
and Jeff Koons arising out of Koons'
use of this photograph as the reference
work for this sculpture.
As you'll recall, Koons'
effort to excuse this behavior
on the basis of the Fair
Use Doctrine failed.
Rogers was thus entitled to damages.
Included in the sum to
which Rogers was entitled
was the profit that Koons earned
as a result of his infringement.
Koons made a lot of money by
selling copies of his sculpture.
Specifically, three of
the four copies he made
were sold to collectors for
a total sum of $367,000.
A substantial portion of
that sum represented profit.
Koons argued, plausibly,
that much of the profit
was attributable to his
own creative contributions,
not to the value he
derived from Rogers photos.
He also argued that some of that
profit derived from a third source,
specifically from Koons'
artistic reputation.
Koons is something of a
star in the art world.
The large amounts that
collectors pay for his works
are attributable, in
large part, to the fact
that Koons made them,
not to their final form.
In this particular case, Koons
contended that Rogers did not
deserve to share in that
reputational premium.
The Court of Appeals for
the Second Circuit agreed.
Here's the pertinent language.
"On the subject of apportioning
profits, the copyright law
requires that Koons have the opportunity
to establish those elements of profit
attributable to factors other
than the copyrighted work.
These elements may include Koons'
own notoriety and his related ability
to command high prices for his work.
To the extent that Koons is able
to prove that the profits at issue
derive solely from his own
position in the art world,
he should be allowed to retain them."
We come finally to the controversial
topic of statutory damages.
Here's how they work.
Section 504(c) provides that at
any point before final judgment
in a copyright case, the
plaintiff may renounce
the recovery of actual damages
and defendant's profits
and instead opt to recover an amount
of money set by a jury or the judge.
How much money?
The pertinent statutory provision
sets forth some broad ranges,
but gives the decision
maker lots of discretion
in picking a point within those ranges.
The currently applicable
ranges appear on your screen.
The default, as you can
see, is between $750
per infringed copyrighted work
and $30,000 per infringed work.
If the defendant's conduct
was willful, meaning
that the defendant knew that his
conduct violated the copyright statute,
then the range is between
$750 and $150,000.
A lower range, as you can see,
applies if the defendant's behavior
was innocent, meaning that
"the infringer was not aware
and had no reason to believe
that his or her acts constituted
an infringement of copyright."
In other words, innocence in
this sense has both a subjective
and an objective component.
To qualify for the lower
range, it's not enough
that a defendant was unaware of
the illegality of his actions.
It's also necessary that his
misimpression had been reasonable.
Who picks the amount of statutory
damages within these broad ranges?
Congress, as you can see
from the text of the statute,
clearly contemplated that "the
court," meaning the trial judge,
would make that determination.
But the United States Supreme
Court in the Feltner case
determined that the Seventh
Amendment provides a right to a jury
trial in all issues pertinent
to an award of statutory damages
under Section 504(a), including
the amount of the award itself.
The upshot is that every time
you see the word court in 504(c),
you should replace it
with the word jury.
What factors should the decision maker
rely upon when setting that amount?
The only guideline the
statute itself provides
is that it should be the amount
that the court considers just.
When, after Feltner, courts delegate
this determination to juries,
they usually instruct the juries to pick
the amount the juries consider just.
Sometimes the judges
suggest other factors
that the jury could consider when
making their choice, such as evidence
of how much the plaintiff was actually
harmed, the need to deter wrongdoing
in the future, the nature of the
plaintiff's work, and so forth.
But these are just suggestions.
Within the ranges set by the statute,
the jury is largely in constraint.
If the defendant has infringed only one
of the plaintiff's copyrighted works,
say a novel or a musical
composition, then as we've seen,
the maximum amount of statutory damages
the plaintiff can recover is $150,000.
But if the plaintiff has infringed
two of the plaintiff's works,
the amount doubles.
If three, it triples, and so forth.
The key variable, to
repeat, is not the number
of occasions on which the defendant
has engaged in an infringement.
It's the number of
works he has infringed.
In some cases, that
number is not obvious.
For example, if I rip a CD
containing 12 sound recordings,
have I infringed one work or 12?
For obvious reasons, it
makes a big difference.
The general standard the courts
use in such circumstances
is that the individual pieces
are deemed distinct works if
and only if they have
independent economic value.
And applying that criterion, courts
unavoidably exercise some discretion
and often tacitly
exercise that discretion
in an effort to do rough justice.
A crucial limitation on the
availability of statutory damages
is that with narrow
exceptions, they are only
available if the plaintiff
registered her work prior
to the defendant's infringement.
As you know from lecture number
six, registration of a copyright
is now optional in the US.
But registration gives a
copyright owner some advantages.
The availability of statutory
damages in case of infringement
is perhaps the most important
of those advantages.
In addition to damages
of these three sorts,
parties who prevail in
copyright infringement suits
can sometimes recover their court
costs and their attorney's fees.
These amounts are not trivial.
Attorney's fees in
particular can be very large.
Indeed, anxiety about possible
liability for attorney's fees
is often the principal
driver that motivates
settlements of infringement suits.
That anxiety derives
in part from the fact
that both costs and attorney's
fees are more commonly
awarded in copyright cases than in
most other types of suit in the United
States.
With respect to both costs
and fees, the trial court
is empowered to make
awards "in its discretion."
The kinds of factors the courts look
to when exercising that discretion
include the strength of the losing
party's substantive arguments--
the stronger they were, the less likely
will be the court to award fees--
the legitimacy of the reasons
why the losing party litigated
the case, the need to deter
abusive litigation by similarly
situated parties in
the future, conversely
the importance of not deterring
legitimate efforts to defend
legal rights or to resolve unsettled
legal issues, and so forth.
The same standards are applied when
assessing requests for costs and fees
made by prevailing defendants as
when assessing such suggestions made
by victorious plaintiffs.
An intriguing variation
on these themes suggested
by Judge Posner in the
Gonzalez case is that a judge
should be more willing
to award attorney's fees,
particularly when the
defendant's behavior was willful,
if the magnitude of the
compensatory or statutory damages
that the plaintiff
could collect is modest.
And thus, unless the plaintiff
could recover such fees,
she might be disinclined
to assert her rights.
Finally, it should be
emphasized that attorney's fees,
like statutory damages, are only
available to copyright owners who
registered their works
prior to the infringement.
This reinforces the incentive
I mentioned a minute ago
to register one's works.
Underlying this rather
intricate combination of rules
are five general themes or objectives.
Sometimes these themes
reinforce one another,
but sometimes they are in tension.
When considering how, if at all, this
system of remedies should be modified,
it's helpful to bring these
objectives to the surface.
When they conflict, it's necessary to
decide which is the more important.
The first, and least surprising purpose,
is to compensate copyright owners.
In other words, to
indemnify them against loss.
A copyright owner who's been injured
by a defendant's infringement
should be able to recoup from
the defendant all of her losses.
All four of the general
theories of copyright law
we have considered in
this lecture series
provide support for
this first objective.
Viewed through the lens of either
fairness or personality theory,
the rights that the law
confers upon copyright owners
are grounded in moral considerations.
The moral right to a fair return
for one's hard creative work,
or the moral right to protection of the
fragile bond between oneself and one's
creations.
Fidelity to those moral
considerations requires at a minimum
that copyright owners not
suffer uncompensated injuries
when their legal rights are abridged.
Viewed through the lens of either
welfare or cultural theory,
the rights that the law
accords authors and artists
are designed to induce them to behave
in ways that will advance some larger
goal, generating and disseminating works
that will advance net social welfare,
or will foster a rich
and stimulating culture.
Authors and artists
will not be so induced
if they are exposed to uncompensated
abridgments of their rights.
So as to this first point,
there's not much controversy.
The second of the objectives is the
prevention of unjust enrichment.
We don't want infringers to
profit from their wrongdoing
even if copyright owners
do not suffer thereby.
This is a very common sentiment.
Not just in copyright law,
but in other fields as well.
It looms large in
contract law, for example.
But despite its ubiquity,
it's harder to justify
and harder to connect convincingly
to the general theories
upon which copyright law rests.
It seems connected to
the same intuition that
prompts us to recoil or object when
a murderer writes a book recounting
his crime and collects
royalties from it.
The third goal helps reinforce
the somewhat shaky foundations
of the second-- deterrence.
We want to craft remedies that
discourage potential infringers
from violating copyright owners'
entitlements in the future.
Litigation is enormously
time consuming and painful.
A copyright owner forced to litigate
can never be truly made whole.
Thus, if possible, we
want to deter people
from infringing their rights
in the first instance.
One way to do so is to award and
publicize monetary judgments that
will make potential defendants
think twice or thrice.
The fourth ambition is punishment.
Copyright infringement is wrong.
We want to penalize the
people who engage in it.
Not just to deter similar
conduct in the future,
but because the infringers deserve it.
Another word for this is retribution.
Finally, copyright law,
as you know by now,
aspires to create and
maintain a delicate balance
between on one hand, the entitlements
of creators, and on the other hand,
the interests of the public in
making use of their creations.
The primary expression of
the latter is the long list
of statutory and judicial
exceptions and limitations.
Embedded in the copyright
statute, the most famous of which
the United States is
the Fair Use Doctrine.
Against this back drop,
we want to craft a set
of remedies that will
maintain that balance.
In particular, just as we want to
ensure that copyright owners have
appropriate incentives
to assert their rights,
so we want to ensure that users
have appropriate incentives
to assert their privileges.
In this respect,
copyright infringement is
fundamentally different
from homicide say, or rape.
In those contexts, we're
not particularly concerned
about over enforcement.
If someone is not entirely
sure what constitutes
manslaughter or sexual
assault and his behavior is,
to use the legal vernacular,
"chilled" a bit, we're not troubled.
That such people are prompted to
steer well clear of a vague line
is not a serious problem.
And copyright law, by contrast, chilling
borderline behavior-- in other words,
discouraging people from engaging in
activities that approach but do not
cross the line of legality--
is a serious problem.
When setting and interpreting the
rules governing damage awards,
we want to avoid it.
By now, the reason why these goals
sometimes conflict should be clear.
Goal number three, and even
more so goal number four,
sometimes counsel larger awards than
is optimal from the standpoint of goal
number five.
The context in which these
considerations are currently
most salient is statutory damages.
Most countries in the
world do not currently
permit copyright owners to
recover statutory damages.
A thorough analysis of the law
of each nation in this regard
can be found in a forthcoming article by
Pam Samuelson, Tara Wheatland, and Phil
Hill.
Phil, as I think you know, is one of
the teaching fellows in the edX course
for which these lectures
were in part prepared.
The authors of that study
demonstrate that only 24
of the 177 member states in the World
Intellectual Property Organization
currently allow recovery
of statutory damages.
And very few of the countries
that do have such regimes also
have copyright based industries
comparable in size and health
to those in the United States.
The US is currently trying to
change the state of affairs.
Its diplomatic representatives
are using various levers
to try to induce other
nations to adopt systems
that resemble the system
in force in the US.
Why?
Primarily because US based organizations
representing at least some copyright
owners have asked them to do so.
Critics of this initiative
make three arguments.
First, many countries,
unlike the United States,
regard punishment of offenders as an
inappropriate function of civil damage
awards.
Punishment, they believe, should be
left to the criminal law, to which we'll
return in the last
segment of this lecture.
The reason why this is
relevant is that over time,
the US system of statutory
damages has gradually
taken on an ever more punitive role.
Originally adopted
primarily as a mechanism
to provide compensation
for copyright owners who
have trouble proving the magnitude
of the injuries they suffer,
it now works in large part
to penalize infringers.
Many observers,
especially outside the US,
think that that's not a
role for private lawsuits.
Second, the critics point
out that the broad ranges
of permissible awards
under the US system
and the paucity of meaningful
guidance concerning how awards should
be set within those ranges give
judges and now juries too much
discretion and result, consequently, in
unpredictable, even arbitrary awards.
Uncertainty of this sort is especially
threatening to the delicate balance
between private rights
and the public interest.
Third, and finally,
some critics point out
that the statutory damage system
generates perverse results
when applied in situations in
which a defendant infringes
a large number of works, each of
which has only modest economic value.
Because as we've seen,
copyright owners are
permitted to recover statutory
damages for each work,
the result is to enable
them to recover amounts
that dwarf the injuries that the
copyright owners actually suffer.
The context in which this unanticipated
problem has proven especially serious
has been file sharing.
The large majority of
the individual defendants
who've been sued by the record
companies for unlawfully copying
and redistributing sound recordings
through file sharing networks
have settled the claims for
modest amounts of money.
But the few defendants who have not
settled have incurred enormous awards.
Jammie Thomas Rasset,
for example, was found
to have infringed the
copyrights in 12 recordings,
and after a series of three
trials, ended up, as you can see,
with a damage award of $222,000.
Joel Tenenbaum was
found to have willfully
violated the copyrights in
30 recordings and ended up
with a damage award of $675,000.
In both of those cases,
the trial judges balked
at the magnitude of the jury's awards.
In both instances, the judges
concluded that the awards
were so large as to violate
the federal constitution.
In both instances, however,
the Court of Appeals reversed.
Although the grounds on which the two
courts of appeals did so differed.
In the Thomas Rasset
case, the Eighth Circuit
rejected the defendant's constitutional
argument on the following ground.
"Applying the Williams
standard, we conclude
that an award of $9,250
per each of the 24 works
is not so severe and oppressive as to be
wholly disproportionate to the offense
and obviously unreasonable."
Congress, exercising its
wide latitude of discretion,
set a statutory damages range for
willful copyright infringement
of $750 to $150,000 per infringed work.
The award here is toward the
lower end of this broad range.
As in Williams, the interests of the
public, the numberless opportunities
for committing the offense, and the
need for securing uniform adherence
to federal law support the
constitutionality of the award.
In the Tenenbaum case, the
First Circuit concluded
that the trial judge should have
avoided the constitutional question.
However, in so ruling,
the First Circuit strongly
intimated that like
the Eighth Circuit, it
believed the Constitution
had not been violated.
In both of these cases, the
United States Supreme Court
declined to review the
Court of Appeals decision.
As a result, we do not yet have
a conclusive answer concerning
the constitutionality of such
applications of the statutory damage
regime.
And we're not likely to get a conclusive
declaration in the near future.
The net result is that the
struggle over statutory damages
will continue in the political arena.
Reformers in the United
States will seek to curb them.
Skeptics in other countries will
likely continue to resist them,
or more modestly, to discipline
statutory damages with guidelines
more precise than the vague
standards used in the US.
By contrast,
representatives of copyright
based industries in
the United States will
continue to defend statutory damages and
argue for the adoption of the US model
elsewhere.
How this struggle will
end remains to be seen.